hey i'm chris hemsworth and this is the
wired auto complete interview
[Music]
uh
okay now so i'm answering what i think
or what
[Music]
all right
how is chris hemsworth is that it
i'm really enjoying being in australia
um i've been away for a while i'm going
to be here for a bit now so i'm excited
i'm excited to be home how did chris
hemsworth
get cast as thor i auditioned for four
many years ago probably 11 12 years ago
and um i didn't get a call back um
i think my audition sucked i think that
was that was the response i got and then
my younger brother auditioned and he got
very close he got down to the last five
people and uh and then didn't get it and
they were like look he's great but he's
a bit young
my manager then said well he does have
an older brother which is me i came back
in re-auditioned a few times and just
had a different attitude maybe i had a
little a little more sort of motivation
that my little brother had got to look
in and i hadn't i also had done a couple
of films in between those two auditions
so i had a bit more experience and
confidence in in what i was going to do
yeah i was so so excited um i had a very
slight hesitation about it was going to
be a six picture deal and didn't want to
be locked in and typecast as one
character and i was like you don't have
a choice so shut up and i pushed that
voice aside and said yep you know i went
but i didn't really know none of us did
if it was going to work or if there was
going to be
an extension beyond that first film into
you know 4-2-3-4 etc or avengers 1 2 3 4
5 whatever it was all just an idea and a
dream and one that i was on board with
how did chris hemsworth
meet wife we
had a dialect coach
that we were both working with
separately who said we should meet and
it was i want to say it was a blind date
but it wasn't because i googled her then
i went away and shot a movie and then i
came back and then we shot another movie
and so it was just kind of a long
extended uh introduction i guess
and then the rest is history
how is chris hemsworth still alive
uh
hmm he uh
i don't know
that's uh it's a luck of the drawer
isn't it i don't know how am i still
alive
none of us know that i could tell you
that
you know it's because i'm healthy and
doing
x y and z but uh you know it hasn't
worked out for some people either and so
you know we've all got aunties and
uncles and grandpas and grandparents who
have done all the wrong things and lived
to a hundred so who knows mate just just
just just enjoy the ride while you can
what does chris hemsworth
want i want to go on a month-long surf
trip uh
throughout indonesia and just
hop from island to island to surf break
to surf break and do nothing but but
surf
and relax and chill you know i've had a
pretty busy run of work for the last 10
years and it's been exciting and and and
fun but i love just to unplug for a
while and that sounds like a pretty good
way to do it for me the ocean is just a
wonderful reset what was chris
hemsworth's
first job well
get ready i used to work for a uh
like a white goods company like fridges
and i used to
fix and repair and clean breast pumps
and milk extractors
yep you didn't miss
miss here that's what was my job and
this
company used to rent them out to various
pharmacies and chemists and they would
come back and they wouldn't work
sometimes they need to be cleaned and i
would clean them and repair them and i
just remember being really bored i
remember sitting
in a factory after work and thinking you
know i'm going to earn my 10 bucks here
or whatever and
and just like i'd make playlists to try
to get me through it music that would
keep me in a sort of calm state and not
want to you know launch that machine
across the wall van morrison the beatles
pink floyd a lot of music that my
parents listened to and i used to kind
of think about what i wanted to do which
was act and
all the you know other exciting things i
wanted to sort of journey into so it was
good you know boredom is kind of a good
space to
do some solid thinking and i did plenty
of that
what
sport oh i've missed one hang on forget
that what is chris hemsworth's
last marvel movie well the last one i
just shot was thor love and thunder and
it may be my last i don't know it was a
wild and fun and wacky experience as all
taika waititi
movies are played that character for 10
11 years now and each time it's been new
and exciting and and this this was no
exception to that it felt very fresh and
it felt like we were
trying something we hadn't tried before
it was uh in tigers words i think a
wacky wild romantic comedy set in space
yeah in the last movie would have been
endgame where we saw
thor in a very disheveled broken sort of
emotional state you know physically
mentally he wasn't quite himself and he
had some work to do so he leaves that
film with the guardians of the galaxy
and embarks on a journey of
self-discovery and that's where we pick
this up so what sports does chris
hemsworth play i surf a lot
um
i love i love staying active i like
being outdoors i like circuit training
kettlebell workouts functional movement
i don't love long distance running i
love swimming my kids and my wife love
horse riding and i do a little bit of
that what is chris hemsworth's favorite
hobby we just kind of talked about that
didn't we
i'll say something else you know i've
really
enjoyed snowboarding lately one of those
sports you do more and more obviously
you get a little better at and so once a
few things clicked into place
it gave me the same
freedom and fun enjoyment and thrill
that surfing gives me but also my kids
do it now and they love it and we can
ski snowboard down the mountain together
and there's not many activities where
you get to do side by side
with your kids where you all truly love
it to the same extent and have the same
thrill and excitement occurring
who is chris hemsworth
uh chris hemsworth is uh an australian
and he is
sometimes has a problem answering
questions
with any wit and charm
who did chris hemsworth
play first my first acting gig was um
well i got cast as somewhat of an extra
on a show called guinevere jones where i
was playing king arthur i had a
lovely
dark red brown wig on period costume and
so on and that was cool that was just
like whoa i'm on a movie set or a tv set
this is what it feels like cause it's my
big break my next
job was a show called the saddle club i
played a young
veterinarian nurse and i was 18 or 19 at
the time scared out of my mind first job
thought this is it this is my shot
put a lot of pressure on myself and it
was like a
deer in the headlights
yeah it's that was just a bundle of
nerves and anxiety
who would chris hemsworth
want to play ah these days who would i
want to play i don't know i don't know
each time it's different you know i
think i want to
do a drama and then along comes a
hilarious comedy and i think okay cool
actually that's fun let's go do that and
vice versa and so on so i don't know
that i have any particular one character
that i want to play as such i just want
to just want to keep having fun keep
enjoying the ride who is chris
samsworth's
favorite actress oh the pressure cape
blanchett i worked with on ragnarok
he's pretty hard to
go by you know being an australian
fellow aussie someone i've looked up to
for many many years and has just
been in some of my favorite films played
some of the best characters on screen
and continues to do it with such grace
and
integrity and has a wonderful sense of
humor and warmth and is kind and
supportive
she uh she's brilliant who is chris
hemsworth's
favorite band oh
i'd say the tuskegee brothers an
australian
singer-songwriter
folk
um
bluesy kind of vibe the lead singer has
one of the best voices
in the music game i think i find the
the music is very
it has a sort of um the van morrison
ray lamontagne
nina simone otis reading
i don't know there's just a mixture of
all these other artists and quite a
nostalgia to their music which i find is
is enjoyable and calming and i can have
it on in the background or i can crank
it up at a party either or i fit
all of my moods
thank you
what is chris hemsworth's haircut
luca vanello is uh the guy i work with
hairdresser on all my movies he makes
all the wigs designs them
cuts my hair so this is this is this is
it this is this is the luca vanilla i've
actually stuck with this haircut i think
for a while now i look back at when i
was on home away this australian tv show
i love that experience it's a lot of fun
but my haircut was
shocking i came in with long hair it was
pretty cool and i wanted to cut it and i
just had this like i don't even know
what it was kind of a mullet kind of a
flat fringe i didn't want to put product
in it and it was just like like bed hair
but not cool bed hair it was it was
it was pretty brutal what is chris
hemsworth's zodiac sign i'm a leo i'm
you know interested if someone wants to
talk about it to me and and tell me
things about it but i haven't used any
of the knowledge to my advantage or it
hasn't helped me understand myself or
anyone else really yet but maybe i
haven't explored it enough i don't know
what is chris hemsworth's personality
i'm fun enthusiastic i think i'm
adventurous i don't love sitting still
and and the fear of boredom certainly
keeps me moving forward and gives me
momentum to try and explore new things
what is
next for chris hemsworth i'm going to
have some down time and really enjoy
being with my family and being home and
being in one place and i feel like i've
been unpacking suitcases and packing
suitcases and traveling across the world
for so many you know years now 10 12
years and it's been
incredible and i'm so so thankful for
all of it but love to just be still for
a while now and inhabit a more simple
slower environment
i have a movie called spider head coming
out which i'm incredibly proud of it's a
futuristic thriller set in a state of
the art penitentiary where inmates have
an opportunity to get reduced sentences
by partaking in experiments involving
mind altering mood altering drugs what
is crucems worth diet i'd like to think
you eat a fairly balanced diet i do do
eat a lot of
protein
but also have a lot of vegetables i
don't eat a huge amount of carbohydrate
i think my body responds to lean protein
more so and healthy fats and vegetables
but like anyone you know i uh
i have a sweet tooth i have a real
appetite and passion for pizza and
burgers and
ice cream and all the
all the bad things you know but i try to
give myself you know sort of an 80 20
rule 80 20 with the you know the good
being 80 and 20 being the the cheat meal
if you will can chris hemsworth sing no
does chris hemsworth like singing loves
it love it really enjoy it but
going off the response of
my family and friends i'd say no
definitely not kangaroo sam's gonna do
an american accent
i'd like to think so yeah i've done some
bad ones and i've done some
that i'm more proud of and it all
depends on you know the prep period you
have
uh the coach you're working with
what
part of america it is and you know if
that's something you uh
you gravitate toward and you know some
of it comes easier some of it doesn't
that's up for you to decide though so
can crew semsworth
play guitar i can play a little bit yeah
i can't say i play really well but i do
enjoy it much like my the singing and
guitar i just don't think anyone else
enjoys it so it's more of a quiet time
kind of mean my own space experience
can chris hemsworth do a backflip no
my son can my son does them repeatedly
until he exhausts himself to the point
and then he goes to sleep can chris
hemsworth
bench 300 pounds
uh
no i don't think so i'm not a big bench
press guy i like i do a lot of push-ups
i'll do dumbbell press
but i don't tend to go too heavy just
because it kind of tweaks my shoulder
and these days you know i i mean for
thor love and thunder
i think i'm the biggest i ever was and
and probably in the best shape i've ever
been in that but it was very strategic
different exercises
um
shaping my physique and then also a very
specific diet but bench press not a big
strength of mine no
does chris hemsworth
have tattoos i do have tattoos yeah um
i have a tattoo here that
robert downey jr had someone design
which was
when we were on the avengers press tour
which we all got i have dr zeus tattoo
because it was a book i read my daughter
a lot when when she was growing up it's
one of her favorite books i have the
series of little
things in my forearms that my daughter
actually drew herself
tattooed and then a sort of
kind of sacred geometry
kind of
whatever tattoo which you could dig out
all sorts of meaning i myself
you know it's just a cool little image
to me
does chris hemsworth have a brother yes
i have two brothers luke and liam
does chris hemsworth i like playing thor
i love playing for played it for many
many years and would continue to do so
if people wanted me to the most
challenging part of playing for is
reinventing it each time and not having
it be
predictable for an audience and having
it be something they've seen before the
goal is to continually try something new
and keep it fresh and then that is a
challenge but part of the fun
does christmas changes accent for thor i
try to yeah it's slowly morphed into a
version of my accent over the years but
initially it was sort of a shakespearean
mid-atlantic accent we were going for i
still have
a feel of that but it's loosened over
the years as my interpretation of the
character has listened to
all right that's it that is all the
questions thank you very much for the
questions they were great they were
intriguing and uh fascinating i'm
surprised to see that those questions
came up and what you were searching for
but there you go you have all the
answers so no need to
you know search anymore here i am
[Music]